uh what's this uh middle left
one this is a [__] amazing manga such
a good what is it tell me about it okay
so guy wakes up in a hospital he has
Amnesia cliche right very cliche yeah
asleep yeah except for some reason he's
found out that he's woken up and he has
a family and everyone in the family has
Amnesia and they don't know what
happened they don't know why they they
all know their family yeah they they
were told that they were family and they
go on a car accident together and they
all have amnesia um and so you know they
kind of like it's this really wholesome
story about this entire family who just
have like Amnesia and they are told that
they're family but can you be family if
you just like told that you have this
bond with each other so they kind of
like it's it's a story about them kind
of like reconnecting and rediscovering
what it means to be a family I wouldn't
I wouldn't necessarily use the word
wholesome wait wait wait Joey Joey Joey
Joey God [__] damn it Joey God
[__] damn it let me let me I realize
I didn't realize you're building up my
bad my bad okay so so yeah it's a story
about them discovering their bonds and
like they're slowly discovering hey [__]
we like being a family together we this
is what being a family means and then
they finally get discharged from the
hospital they go home he the main
character goes in goes into his room and
his room is just filled from ceiling to
ground with the words die like just
scribbled like everywhere just like
something something has gone on and he
rushes out and he's [__] panicking
and every single family member has had
that same reaction after going to their
rooms they're just like they they're
like guys uh yeah what's uh what the
[__] is happening let's have a meal
right and they don't talk about it and
you're like holy [__] what has happened
to this family and that's chapter one oh
wow right cool and as the story unfolds
you
realize what has gone on with each
different family member some of the
[__] up [__] that has happened behind
the scenes that we don't know about
because for some reason everyone has
Amnesia and without spoiling it that's
pretty coincidental they car with the
carbon monoxide yeah and that's pretty
unusual that they all happen to have
Amnesia and
it's it just started this year and it's
it's rare that I have a manga that just
immediately gripped me from chapter one
and this is what I it's still [__]
good this is what this is the page
Turner manga for me when you finish the
chapter you're like there's a Twist and
you're like holy [__] I need to read the
next one I need to read the next one
honestly it's this Artist as well
because uh they did one before this one
called
Taco uh which is kind of in a similar
vein where like there's this alien
creature that this girl finds called
Tule and uh and he like tries to like
you know befriend this like alien kind
of creature and something happens to her
and in her vicinity that is like
absolutely [__] up um and takoi this
character uh realizes that like he can
only once every couple of like periods
of time that they can teleport back to
the past at a certain point and so this
girl uses this this alien's power to go
back in time to try and like her future
of like the [__] up [__] and this
author has this really interesting style
where like they have such a cutesy
wholesome looking
likees but has created some of the most
[__] up stories all right I'm I'm sold
that's sounds awesome and this one is as
well is really fun like whoa and I first
read it this one hits the ground running
and it hasn't stopped yet T as well like
first chapter is just [__] yeah yeah
exactly okay I'm sold you sold me boys
and that's all I'm going to say about it
it is a mystery manga so I don't want to
say too much so read it yourselves I
guess just read it I just want to sell I
just wanted to sell it uh one piece live
AC I keep thinking about this I keep
having people come to me and ask me
about it you know what now in retrospect
after however many months it's been
since I finished watching this I think I
finally realized just how much I enjoyed
the [__] out of this live action right
like I think I came I think I came into
this too much as just a seasoned Anime
Watcher who had just been Jed we've been
burned I I think when everyone's like
see guys we told you going be good it's
like no no no no you this up for like 30
years back to back you don't you don't
get to just be like see we were right it
was going to be good now [__] off I
think everyone everyone was very
Justified and they're worry about
hearing this oh totally but obviously
everyone's very relieved that it's good
yeah and the more friends and more
family members that have absolutely zero
interest in anime because more keep
coming up as like I just as the years
going on where they just kept asking me
about one piece and I just it just made
me realize holy [__] this was this is
why every studio is trying to make a
live action and this is now the standard
of big high-profile liveaction
adaptations because it just kind of
especially Western production as well
yeah especially Western Productions and
I really really hope that we haven't
opened Pandora's box with this one we
have H I mean you H your actions coming
out and I'm really scared that's already
out oh is it out already yeah well I
know what I'm watching okay
actually have you seen it I've seen a
few episodes and it's actually pretty
decent oh okay wow there is there is
this one fight scene because one of one
of the big things that I didn't know
what how they were going to do was cuz I
think the first Ark of Yaki was one of
the weakest ones well yeah it starts off
as a slice how do you make it compelling
yeah they had this one fight scene with
one of the demons that that very much
felt like a jackiechan movie or like an
old school Kung Fu like the camera work
in that was [__] insane it's not just
T yeah I mean yeah theoretically if it
you
know these people now are being brought
up on anime who are directing these
things and watching it it should it
should get better and you know if one
piece has kind of set the the stage now
saying hey look we you can do it yeah
yeah then we should theoretically get
more good liveaction adaptations yeah
and it's not to say there haven't been
like you know just as good live actions
or better than the one piece live action
cuz like there have been like there's
been a couple of live actions I've seen
that are actually I think better than
the one piece live action but it's just
we had so many misses in between that
time as well yeah still worried about
how they'll continue with it because
that's still the big question how are
they going to bring Chopper into the
equation that's my biggest question how
do they how do they do this all before
they all get old how do you you know you
have to commit this is it's just one of
those things where it's like like yeah I
think they they've nailed it now but
like going forward is like a real big
question mark and that's was always
going to be tough with one I think I
think they they've done what they've
needed to do uh and they've introduced
one piece to a larger audience because
God forbid one piece fans are the most
toxic now anyway so what's the hard TV
Works gone if a TV show is popular you
know we got to get them Seasons out of
it you I was going to say prior to today
that I honestly think that this is the
best way to get someone into one piece
but oh my God we just got announced
today that one piece is getting a
[__] remake what they're doing one
piece Brotherhood before one piece is
even finished yeah which is probably
going to be now the new best way to get
someone into one piece I I guess we'll
see how how it goes when they start
releasing I mean one piece fans uh we
we've been eating very very well this
year we've had gear five we've had the
one piece live action we had now a new
remake coming out they realized an
infinite money glitch which is just
using the one piece IP in any way yeah
it's kind of weird to thing that one
piece is now peeking after like what 25
years yeah almost 30 years yeah yeah
it's still it's still got new Peaks uh
excited to see where it goes all right
everything here was way too [__]
vanilla I wanted to throw in some spice
I wish I I wish I could have put a hent
on mine but there I didn't think there
was any good hentai this [__] this one
this one looks like really [__] artsy
like what is this okay so this is this
is this is a d jinci okay uh I F that
much henai this year [__] sucks so
bad sucks this is probably the worst
year of hentai since I've started
watching hentai so five years yeah just
wash so just the [__] wash your hand
yeah definitely um I wouldn't recommend
this Doan if you want to yank it I'll be
honest okay uh I I wanted to put this on
because is this like a metamorphosis
kind of okay yeah I got that Vibe I got
that Vibe I like this looks too dark and
gritty I was like man I didn't realize
the menu had a weird ass poster oh no
it's just a [__] big ass blank box I
thought I thought Alex just [__] up on
like the the cropping and I was just
like oh okay yeah um so this kind of
takes place in a cyberpunk world M where
basically sex Androids exist
and uh people can buy sex Androids so
Japan in about 20 years time we're close
we're getting yeah we get any about 20
years and you start like chapter 2
chapter chapter one chapter two and
you're like oh the art in this is great
it's kind of got like that cyber Punk
aesthetic it it looks like a yoshitoshi
Ab mang like like a Serial experiments
Lane Vibe kind of kind of yeah it's it's
kind of very much that Vibe the art is
great and then they start like
developing the characters
and you're and you're like okay I'm I'm
still like like put your pants away
you're like
okay I'm listening you're like actually
this makes it even [__] better
because now now I'm invested in the
characters as well and then there is
just this one chapter where bad things
happen to the characters yeah and I
don't think I've had that kind of
emotional reaction to a [__] Doan I
think ever wow like with metamorphosis I
think with metamorphosis I was like I
know I'm getting into I'm like prepared
for it with this one I was just like
having a joy like a jolly old time and
then like you turn the page and you're
like oh oh my god oh is it like is it
like like era guro territory or um I
wouldn't say arur it's it's what the
[__] does arur mean like violent Jes CH
eror it's it it is very much violent but
I the reason I think it's [__] like
because it's like to do with Androids
Tech's it me realize that feel these
like emotions just because I was that
attached to some of like the Android
characters in it and I was like wait a
minute this a really [__] good story
as well and so much so you'd recommend
it so much so I recommend people
experience it um this definitely looks
like something I'd get into yeah yeah
yeah I was I was like Jo you go just
from the look of it I'm like yeah I
think I was like jery try this one out
try this one out I'll give it a read I'm
going to say I'm not going to say too
much about it but it it just like I want
most of the things I put on here are
things that have surprised me over the
years over this year because I didn't
want to put any anime on there and most
of the films and games we've talked
about already so like this one uh this
one definitely surprised me uh I wasn't
expecting that and I had a very very
strong emotional reaction and to me
that's what art is all about sure even
if you come into this for a totally
different [__] reason that
is that is what Art's all about you're
definitely coming into this that's for
sure um I mean this one was not so much
villain Saga season 2 it was how
surprising it was for me that a
wholesome Meme got spread around this
year this was my favorite meme this year
I have no enemies I no enemies yeah yeah
we said plent I'm I'm not going I'm not
going to say too much about this because
I mean it very much Builds on the power
of villain Saga season 2 and the message
they had in general uh so much so that
it actually gave the internet a
wholesome Meme and I think the internet
could do with more wholesome memes this
year for sure that's true it did it did
kind of get the internet by storm for
about a week or two yeah uh which I
appreciate it's good mean the internet
was a safe place for about week